celebrations the second big royal
wedding this year are taking place in
Windsor England right now the
granddaughter of Queen Elizabeth
Princess Eugenie married tequila brand
ambassador Jack Brooksbank this morning
the lavish ceremony echoed Prince Harry
and Meghan markle's wedding just five
months ago in the very same location
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside Saint
George's Chapel with the festivities
Jonathan good morning good morning to
Vlad that ceremony ending just a short
time ago you can still see some people
gathered here outside the chapel this
was not quite the blockbuster we all
tuned in to watch just a few months ago
it was much more of an intimate family
affair there were similarities similar
guest list and of course that very
romantic carriage ride there was though
one notable unwelcome difference you
could tell just by looking at the
flapping of that flag a lot of wind 60
mile-per-hour gusts grabbed at
fascinators and even swept the page boys
and bridesmaids off their feet this
morning's windy wedding revival brought
the whole family back together along
with some of the Royals closest friends
actress Demi Moore joined model Kate
Moss and actors Cara Delevingne among
others at Windsor's st. George's Chapel
it's the same venue where in May
American actress Megan Markel married
Prince Harry today they took the back
seat not far from Queen Elizabeth and
Prince Philip as well as the Duke and
Duchess of Cambridge who all looked on
as princess eugenie granddaughter of the
Queen married Jack Brooksbank I usually
Victoria Elena
five-year-old preached George the future
King of England reprised his role as
Paige Boyd and his three-year-old sister
Charlotte was one of the six bridesmaids
it was a dazzling display of love and
pageantry as crowds go it wasn't the
same blockbuster as that other wedding
but this sequel still had its own
fairytale ending and Princess Eugenie
does not serve an official public role
which has led to some criticism
specifically surrounding the price tag
of this wedding
taxpayers doing at about two million
dollars in security though others are
very quick to point out with the Queen
and to future Queen Kings all inside of
this chapel that price tag perhaps well
worth it John
Jonathan Vigliotti in the Windy Windsor
thank you Jonathan
need a fastener for your fascinator but
the Queen you know she unflappable
answer everybody stability always